In rT traffic shaping, traffic is divided into T-bit
frames. And a flow can inject less than or
equal to r bits in any T-bit frame. If
the sender wants to send more than one packet
of r bits, it simply has to wait until
the next T-bit frame. A flow that obeys this
rule has what is known as an rT smooth
traffic shape. In the case of rT smooth traffic
shaping, one cannot send a packet that's larger
than r bits long. Unless T is very long,
the maximum packet size may be very small.
So the range of behaviors is typically limited to
fixed rate flows. Variable flows have to request
data rates that are equal to the peak rate,
which is incredibly wasteful. If you have to
configure the shaper such that the average must support
whatever peak rate the variable rate flow may send.
The rT traffic shaper is slightly relaxed from a
simple leaky bucket because rather than sending one packet
every time unit, the flow can send a certain
number of bits every time unit. Now there's a
question of what to do when a flow exceeds
a a particular rate. And typically what's done is
that if a flow exceeds it's rate, the excess
packets in that flow are given a lower
priority. And if the network is heavily loaded or
congested, the packets from a flow that exceeds a
rate may be preferentially dropped. Priorities might be assigned
at the sender, or at the network. At the
sender, the application may mark its own packet, since
the application knows best which packets may be less
important. In the network, the routers may mark packets
with a lower priority, which is sometimes called policing.